[Música]
hola hola muy bien no quisieron
presentarme nuevamente pero bueno como
están como ven tratar de bien hoy
explicó aparecer y como comentaba soy
ingeniero de sistemas apasionado por la
tecnología pero hoy vamos hablar de
cosas que no tienen nada que ver con lo
que hago todos los días
y vamos a
hacernos algunas preguntas clave
entonces voy a necesitar que cerremos
todos nuestros ojos y nos relajemos y lo
que vamos a hacer por sacar su primero
voy a ver que todos sirven los ojos de
pelos y rollo
todo cerrado muy bien una vez tengamos
los ojos cerrados
quiero que respiren profundamente
respiremos profundamente todos por favor
expulsamos la respiración inhalamos
nuevamente
salimos inhalamos exhalamos soltemos
nuestros hombros no nos vayamos a dormir
y ahora vamos a hacer lo siguiente
quiero que todos se trasladen a un salón
un salón grande muy bonito un salón que
tiene una luz tenue y cuando nosotros
ingresamos a ese scrum quiero que se
imaginen que están todos sus seres
queridos todas las personas que
realmente a ustedes les importa en su
vida
saludamos a las personas vamos caminando
y nos encontramos al final del salón un
ataúd y como somos curiosos vamos a
caminar hasta el ataúd y cuando miremos
al ataúd nos sorprendemos porque nos
encontramos nosotros mismos significa
que es el día de nuestro velorio así es
el día de nuestro velorio estamos súper
sorprendidos y tenemos la opción de
elegir a una sola persona de todos los
seres que diremos que tenemos en ese
salón para que hablen sobre ti
que creen que dirá esa persona sobre ti
imaginémonos en este momento por favor
todos que está diciendo esa persona
sobre ti
hoy
ahora vosotros por favor
parece que algunas personas tenía mucho
que decir de ustedes eso es muy bueno
este es un ejercicio muy importante que
nos ayuda a resolver algunas preguntas
que son claves
cuáles son esa pregunta estoy haciendo
algo importante en mi vida
mi vida tiene algún rumbo
tengo algún propósito de vida en este
momento es más si tengo un propósito de
vida definido lo que estoy haciendo es
decir todas mis acciones que hago en el
día mi forma de ser mi forma de actuar
las personas con las que me relaciono me
están llevando llevando a que yo cumpla
ese propósito de vida por supuesto son
preguntas que normalmente nos hacemos
lastimosamente cuando entramos a una
época de crisis cuando hay un quiebre
cuando sufre un accidente cuando sé que
me van a operar y tengo peligro de
muerte y cuando mi madre está mal mi
padre está mal y lógicamente no debería
hacer esos momentos que sean los
disparadores para que yo me haga esas
preguntas
por supuesto yo también me hice esas
preguntas más de una vez y cuando me las
hice
me dije a mí mismo a mí mismo a partir
de este momento a partir de este momento
es y va a ser tu vida tu mejor negocio
es y va a ser tu vida la de cada uno de
ustedes su mejor negocio y como todo
negocio que necesita un plan de negocio
para mí no era un plan de negocio era un
plan de vida es decir un propósito como
todo negocio necesita inversión
invertir esfuerzo para que lo han dicho
los anteriores speaker para mejorar como
persona desarrollar habilidades
destrezas experiencia físicamente
mentalmente espiritualmente lo que nos
haga mejores personas
necesito invertir bien
y por supuesto necesito invertir dinero
y presión económica sobre mí también me
di cuenta a partir de ese momento que
todos nosotros
tenemos un negocio el más importante que
somos nosotros del cual somos gerente
propietario y del cual somos el único
empleado y del cual debería ser
protagonista
de ese negocio llamado vida
ahora no es fácil uno dice perfecto me
hice la pregunta tengo un propósito de
vida tengo un rumbo tengo un horizonte
ay desatenciones hay desvío de atención
me comenzó a desenfocar hay obstáculos
en la vida comienzo a dejar de creer en
mí mismo en mi habilidad en mi
experiencia y todo se comienza a poner
un poco borroso a todos nos pasa
todo lo que parecía claro parecía
sencillo parecía que estaba encaminado
no lo es
y aparecen otros negocios que llamo yo
son negocios corporativos cercanos un
negocio llamado familia un negocio
llamado amigos de verdad amigos de
verdad un negocio llamado padre un
negocio llamado hijo que nos hacen que
nosotros rediseñamos ese propósito de
vida y que no solamente tengamos un plan
sino además cambiemos cosas lo decían
hace un momento si yo no cambio sigo
haciéndolo vemos el resultado el mismo
por supuesto entonces es hora de asumir
cambios en nuestra vida una vez tengo un
propósito bien definido
hacemos tres cambios que yo les puedo
comentar que a mí me resultan y con ello
logre identificar un propósito más
grande
antes y me decía cuál es tu propósito mi
propósito es ser un buen padre no ese
nuevo propósito tienes que ser un buen
padre eso lo tienes que hacer bien sí o
sí no hay elección entonces voy a hacer
un excelente marido
te estás pasando por algo tenéis que
hacer lobby tienes que ser un buen
marido eso no no es un propósito de vida
un buen hijo por supuesto que no tenéis
que ser un buen hijo tenéis que hacer lo
mío un buen profesional si estás
estudiando lo tenéis que servir y un
buen ciudadano por favor hay que ser un
buen ciudadano
ninguno de ellos son propósitos de vida
entonces
comencé a pensar y dije voy a ser el
mejor ingeniero de sistemas bebé
especializado de la mejor manera
certificaciones posgrados todo lo que
ustedes se imaginan pero al final como
decía lo logro de una línea a tope y
medio de motivo perfecto ya me
conocieron capaz entre los 10.000
mejores del sistema bolivia me sirve
entonces descubrí que ese no era mi
propósito cuando me lo reformulen mi
propósito lo cambien y lo cambie lo
siguiente
poner a bolivia en el mapa de la
innovación tecnológica mundial
es decir desarrollar tecnología y ahí
justamente construimos una software
factory y luego desarrollamos empresas
de base tecnológica siempre pensando en
escalarla no pensarla y una base
santacruz y ahí termina si tengo una
base de bolivia una base paraguay una
base argentina porque no podemos hacer
cosas similares
bienvenido a hacer esto esto cambio
casualidad o causalidad debemos dejar de
pensar que las cosas suceden porque dios
es grande o porque tenía que suceder no
por supuesto dios no va a la vida no da
amor no a la posibilidad de hacer cosas
pero nosotros somos los responsables de
hacer las cosas
esto se entendí profundamente
simplemente tipo que alguien dirá lo que
va a decir por supuesto que tiene que
ser así pero yo lo entendí profundamente
de que todos nosotros somos líderes de
nuestra vida líderes de nuestras
decisiones que tomamos todos los días
y que es el conjunto de acciones que yo
realizo todos los días ya sean acciones
positivas acciones negativas me van a
llevar a cumplir o no ese gran propósito
de vida
es decir tomar el control de nuestras
vidas lo siguiente es poco perfecto ya
tengo un horizonte ya sé hacia dónde
quiero llegar qué es lo que quiero hacer
cómo quiero trascender cómo quiero que
me recuerden las personas queridas y
volvemos al primer ejercicio era ese el
fondo quiero que me recuerden como
alguien trivial no yo creo que todos han
tenido familiares ahora en el álbum ese
no era el tío raúl a ver creo que no
joven así que el tío raúl y era casado
siguiera casado o no o sea apenas y no
queremos que atrás queremos trascender o
no queremos trascender los siguientes y
el foco es decir enfocarme e identificar
que hice yo identifique todos aquellos
desvíos de atención que no permitían que
yo me enfoqué y que mis acciones me
llegan a cumplir mi meta
y comportamientos que también son
círculos viciosos de vido de atención
puede ser desde el hecho que todos los
días me levanto aburrido si te estás
echando a las 12 de la noche porque
todos los días en una serie de netflix
por supuesto que te va a levantar
aburrido
no es que soy una persona impuntual no
creo que haya nacido en puntual no mi
madre me tuvo a los nueve meses y dos
días
para navarro o sea no por eso va a ser
impuntual salió me doy cuenta
como decía todo conciencia de lo que soy
y lo debo cambiar eso denominamos tenido
de atención y comportamientos que se
convierten en círculo vicioso porque yo
soy consciente de que soy así y no hago
nada para cambiarlo no si no soy así
déjame tranquilo más y flojo no naciste
flow so mentir naciste seguro con un
propósito de vida y lo tenés que
identificar lo tenés que cumplir
entonces qué puedo hacer yo con los
genios de atención lo puedo controlar
en algunos puedo influir
por ejemplo llegar tarde controlable
duermo más temprano pongo el despertador
más temprano si vivo lejos entonces le
aseguro que llego temprano y lo
convierte en un hábito
esto no pero es que el tráfico por eso
puedes influir en el tráfico a date por
otra ruta de bastante más temprano y
aquellas cosas que no las puedo
controlar y que no las puedo influir
debo aprender a convivir con ella y si
no me suman nada a mi propósito de vida
me alejo no me sirve hablemos de malas
amistades de marcos malos círculos de
amigos vicios que no me suma
absolutamente nada a mi vida
a mí me resta
y el tercero que considero que es uno de
los más importantes
tengo un propósito
controla las emociones
pero si mi exactitud sigue siendo
exactamente la misma que esto ya tiene
que ver cómo voy a hacer las cosas como
el how
y ahí me di cuenta de que hay que
cambiar de modo es como que tengamos un
modo o un modo off
es decir cambiar modo actitud y ximo
primo creo que no sirve para cambiar
realmente
de modo pesimista donde todos lo vemos
mal parece que nos ponemos una lente
donde todo está mal está mal
todo lo hemos mal de modo pesimista a
modo optimista
me cambio los lentes o me cambio el
sombrero algo cambiar para ver las cosas
de otra manera a todos nos pasa no es
santa cruz es la típica queja llega
septiembre o sea primavera qué calor
zaga no se puede trabajar
esperamos que el sur que haya viento
cuando elija enero y 9 no puede trabajar
efe no puede salir de mi casa no pasan
micro y que está lloviendo no sabía no
sabía qué dinero yo bien entonces que no
trabaje nadie
sí
de modo víctima a modo protagonista
no victimizamos todo y la realidad
terminamos siendo víctima parecemos
novela mexicana víctimas de todo
yo los invito a que seamos protagonistas
seamos líderes lo decían hace un momento
y me gustó bastante la presentación del
liderazgo al servicio a las otras
personas seamos líderes nosotros mismos
sino ligero mi persona
mi forma de actuar peor voy a liderar
grupo de personas
y por último de carencia a modo
abundancia todos tenemos la mentalidad
de crisis
siempre nos falta algo para cumplir con
nuestros objetivos buscamos excusas nos
victimizamos buscamos excusas de nuestra
mediocridad en otras personas
yo la verdad que por culpa de impuestos
no habrá empresa posible no se puede en
este país como lo hicieron las grandes
empresas entonces
es posible no el costo laboral es alto
es para todos el coste lograr al modelo
analizarlo y si quieres entrar en el
juego no entra londres está claro
no lo que pasa es que yo no heredé plata
pero cómo voy a hacer empresa
yo no soy yo dejamos de un grupo
empresarial pero hacerlo entonces voy a
iniciar todo empresarial
hacerlo con las personas 3 personas 5 10
20 hace las cosas bien hechas
y por eso los invito a que hagamos un
último ejercicio por favor
y pasemos a conectar lo primero a
desconectarlo de lo que no tengo no
tenemos muchas cosas obviamente nos
faltan muchas cosas y eso lo primero que
tenemos que hacer y quiero que se
conecten con lo que tienen en este
momento
quiero que todos ustedes hagan una lista
mental de al menos
345 n cosas que ustedes tienen en su
vida y que no valoran
cosas que no agradecen todos los días
estamos hablando de cosas tan simples
como capaz el poder levantarme todos los
días el tener salud el poder gozar de
agua caliente para ducharme el poder
tener agua potable simplemente cuando me
dirijo al lavaplatos
agro y tomo agua así de sencillo
tener un hogar tener un trabajo
el hecho de tener oportunidades de
cambiar nuestro rumbo no sé por favor un
ejercicio súper sencillo mental
lógicamente no vamos a compartir de
estas cosas que parecen triviales que le
damos por sentado a todos los días pero
que las tenemos en nuestra vida gracias
tómense 1 minuto
segundo qué va
bing
lo que vamos a hacer ahora es aquellas
personas que sienten profunda pero
realmente profunda gratitud
y quiero agradecer por la lista que
tienen ahora en su mente
por esa lista recuerden la lista quiero
que por favor
se pongan de pie lo que agradece por
cualquier cosa que hemos hecho que se
pongan de pie y aplaudan van a aplaudir
al agradecimiento quiero que aprendan
que salten que griten que destruyen el
jueves y quiero que ustedes
agradezcamos a la cama por estar vivos
por estar sanos por tener amigos por
tener familia por tener compañeros por
tener una oportunidad de trabajo por
tener un hogar sin apoyo de ustedes solo
agradezcan agradezcan a la vida es
verdad no lo hacemos y lo máximo
están destruyendo por allá por si acaso
el lugar está bien ahora no vamos a
llevar
como última acción de la presentación
con propósito porque al final de cuentas
hemos dicho que nuestra vida nuestro
mejor negocio espero que eso haya
quedado claro
pero quiero que nos lleven a un
propósito hoy y quiero que repitan
conmigo
mi propósito inmediato
quiero que repitan conmigo por favor yo
sé que se casaron pero no podemos hacer
mi propósito inmediato
es encontrar mi propósito de vida
y tal pero diciendo ojalá que encuentren
su propósito de vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]